bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur la france comment vous vous
interprétez vous analysé sept procès du
journaliste khaled rares initiés oui
bonjour à tous et à toutes
oui c'est un aveu de faiblesse du
pouvoir algérien c'est vraiment un abus
de 1,1 régime aux abois
parce que il n'a plus de légitimité sur
le plan institutionnel tout le monde
connaît et se rappelle de la mascarade
des élections présidentielles c s'il
n'ya plus de séparation vraiment entre
la sphère présidentielle civile et la
sphère militaire puisque c'est l'armée
qui dirige tout et même les commandes et
les services de renseignement ils ne
jouent plus leur rôle de régulateur
parce qu'ils ont été démantelés de à
l'époque de bouteflika et puis les plus
les principaux dirigeants de ceux de ses
services en prison il s'agite au trafic
de tags et en plus bon le pouvoir comme
une erreur stratégique en pensant que
grâce ou à cause du coc vide les
manifestations le irak à cesser et qu'il
pourra continuer la répression et ainsi
affaiblir le mouvement mais en même
temps ils oublient que ce ce
cette pandémie a causé des souffrances
sur le plan humain des décès mais
surtout surtout la baisse drastique des
ressources des hydrocarbures c'est à
dire le caser et le pétrole l'algérie
donc engrangé que 20 milliards de
dollars de recettes à cause de la baisse
des prix du pétrole mais aussi à cause
de la baisse de la demande mondiale pour
les raisons qu'on connaît c'est à dire
une tête de la de l'activité et cela ne
suffira pas à garder les réserves de
change les réserves de changes s'épuise
donc l'algérie va de rentrer dans un
arbre dans une nouvelle posture de pays
endettés et surendettés même hélas cette
période terrible que j'ai bien connu
quand j'allais en algérie dans les
années 80 a emporté mais vraiment toutes
les industries parce qu'on n'y avait
plus possibilité d'apporter les produits
semi finis donc l'arrestation du
journaliste raven y vient dans un
contexte très compliqué pour le pouvoir
il ya des inquiétudes légitimes d'un
décès entre guillemets suite au co vide
c'est à dire que alors que normalement à
prisonnier il est
s'il est bien gardé s'il n'est pas sujet
à être contaminée donc on peut prétexter
de cela donc y ait des menaces sur sa
vie parce que le dossier lui même il est
vide il n'y a pas de preuve pas de
preuve c'est que ces complicités aussi
publicité avec une puissance étrangère à
la draille nick est poursuivi pour
incitation un rassemblement non armés
attentes à l'unité nationale sont des
accusations
très grave il risque une dizaine
d'années de prison ce n'est pas le seul
journaliste visé aujourd'hui par le
pouvoir algérien avec d'autres cas ça
révèle quoi aujourd'hui sur ce mouvement
du irak d'ailleurs parlez nous un peu de
ce mouvement du rac et le lien avec
justement la répression des journalistes
il y avait une chaussure de john baez
qui disait c'est pas parce que la rue
est calme que tout va bien et vraiment
on peut l'appliquer à l'algérie ce n'est
pas parce que il n'ya plus de
manifestations parce que les
manifestants y compris les organisateurs
même si ce ne sont pas officialisé
savent très bien que ils ne peuvent pas
risquer la vie de centaines de milliers
d'algériens d'algérie a donc le irak a
été responsable il a donc mis en
sourdine ses manifestations
mais cela ne signifie pas donc un retour
à la situation
ex ante et c'est à dire que le pouvoir
il n'a plus de légitimité même la
légitimité d'un dada d'une armée
populaire au service des citoyens vole
en éclats parce que maintenant les noces
et sont sortis y compris le régime le
régime lui même a été acculé à sortir
des dossiers de corruption
donc là il n'ya plus de secret ben ce qu
on disait dans la presse sur toutes les
affaires de détournement de fonds et de
faux publique et maintenant c'est devenu
une évidence
donc là il ya un discrédit donc de
l'appareil militaire tel qu'il est
dirigé cette à l'ensemble de l'appareil
militaire
c'est l'état major seulement le pouvoir
n'a plus les moyens d'entretenir la paix
sociale commune faisait à box qu'il
avait quand même en 2014
les réserves de choses sont arrivées de
200 milliards de en hameau de mots
camille sari chaque c'est difficile
aujourd'hui l'algérie c'est retrouve un
peu finalement le l'ère bouteflika ou
pas aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on est encore
dans ces cas de figure il n'y a pas eu
de rupture
c'est ce héros parce que bouteflika ils
avaient entre parenthèses ce qu'on doit
rendre l'état citant c'est que c'était à
son riche les guerres bon mais nouveau
régime
le il n'a pas de deux il n'a pas de
recours le président et hépatiques ou
monsieur dépatie d'été boon génie
extérieur la france et c'est à la salle
intéresse pas vraiment les jeunes et et
puis surtout qui n'avaient pas les
moyens financiers pour décharger partie
par la rancoeur de raki dans les esprits
il est chez les gens dont c'est un rêve
camille sari merci beaucoup et je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'institut euro maghrébin d'étude et de
prospective